they are outstanding and innovative
reports about some of the most important
issues of our time from race relations
income inequality and the Ebola outbreak
to gender identity and cancer the
biggest stories around the world from
Syria to Russia and Africa an ambulance
brings more victims six members of the
same family and as always investigative
reporting that uncovered abuse of power
and corruption inside the men were
packed wall-to-wall eight to a room the
16 winners of this year's Alfred I
DuPont Columbia University Awards
highlight outstanding news reporting
across platforms by networks cable in
Tetouan on local television stations on
the radio and online from 2014 to 2015
and millions upon millions of organisms
can be lurking in those tanks eight of
this year's awards feature investigative
reporting from there we want to I
thought well she can one winning team
tracks an immigrant crisis far from its
backyard tens of thousands of children
across the border here alone another
attracts a cultural shift and the
struggles that come with it I've been
thinking about this day forever there
are both veteran reporters and something
very new faces and for the first time
this new winning platform for the last
year I've spent every working day trying
to figure out where a high school kid
was for an hour after school one day in
1999 these awards on her stories told
and a changing media landscape by
risk-taking journalists who helped
define public service the dupatta wards
were established in 1942 by jesse ball
dupont and memory of her husband alfred
i dupont they are administered by
Columbia University's Graduate School of
Journalism congratulations to the
winners of the 2016 DuPont awards